Aunque el presidente francés Emmanuel
macron ya abandonado china sus dichos
respecto a las tensiones entre gigante
asiático y Taiwán siguen resonando
macron volvió a referirse a la postura
de Francia sobre la autonomía de La Isla
estamos a favor
esta política es constante no ha
cambiado es la política de una sola
China y la búsqueda de una solución
pacífica del problema eso es lo que le
dije al presidente chino que Se repitió
por todas partes no hemos cambiado
los comentarios del mandatario francés
se dan después de que en una de sus
entrevistas asegurara que Europa no debe
seguir ni a Washington ni a Beijing
comentarios que cayeron mal con el
expresidente estadounidense Donald Trump
quien lo acusó de ir a besar traseros en
China este miércoles listas la ex
primera ministra británica que apenas
duró 6 semanas en el cargo también
reprobó el viaje de macron a China
fue un error de los líderes occidentales
visitar al y pedirle que intervenga para
buscar una solución al conflicto en
Ucrania
creo que fue una señal de debilidad
también es por eso que está mal que el
presidente sugiera que Taiwán Es
simplemente algo que no es de interés
directo para Europa no estoy de acuerdo
con eso en absoluto
desde donde respaldaron al francés fue
de Alemania país que remarcó que están
trabajando en una política de China a
nivel de la Unión Europea
nosotros junto con Francia y otros
socios estamos muy interesados en
mantener el orden basado en normas y en
paz y estabilidad en toda la región
el tema de Taiwán sigue generando álgias
reacciones de China que consideran la
isla como una provincia Rebelde la
postura militarista de Beijing se
incrementó en días recientes con nuevos
ejercicios militares tras la visita a la
presidenta saying a Estados Unidos